I think it comes down to equality which
is I think such a silly thing to say in
2008 but I think it comes down to sort
of civil rights the right to get married
the right to you know file your taxes
together hospital visitation rights and
and I think beyond that is equality
including in the military with don't ask
don't tell which seems to always be a
hot-button issue that pops up but you
know once a year or so but especially
now with the presidential debate and
candidates taking a side on the issue
but I think it comes down to basic civil
rights because I think it remains even
among people who claim to support gay
rights I think it remains a taboo
subject in that while if we're saying
the majority of America has no problem
with gay people I think that there's an
asterisk that position no problem with
gay people so long as you're not my son
so long as you're not my sister and I
think the idea of introducing that and
into one's personal life whether people
will own up to it or not remains an
issue I think it's very easy from the
bubble of New York or LA to say you know
this should be a non-issue but they're
so much so many opinions and views in
between those coasts that don't
necessarily agree with that and I think
it's very clear that evangelical and
very conservative religious groups
maintain quite a bit of power in this
country because there are you know it's
very clear that candidates are are
leaning one way or the other one when it
comes to their approach of them and
their viewpoints have to be taken
seriously on the political spectrum and
that's the you know it's there that
these things are going to change
I have a I have a personal issue with
the idea that some people can tolerate
homosexuality I do not tolerate women I
do not tolerate black or Asian people I
embrace them as I would anyone else and
so I think right now we're sending this
message of tolerance and I think it is a
stepping stone toward embracing or even
so much so that it's a non-issue I think
right now that the goal needs to be to
promote this as a normalized sort of
behavior and I think that if we're
taking these sort of band-aid or
sideways approaches to get to a final
result we're going to end up with
something that's still not viewed very
well so the I think the message we need
to be pitching is this sort of
normalized behavior gay people are just
like straight people they just sleep
with the same sex I mean that's there's
really all it comes down to I think it's
easy for me to say that's such a simple
message not only because I live in a
very urban area but I'm a gay man you
know on the same token I don't think
it's very easy for you know other folks
and more conservative parts of the
country to accept that message you know
I'm a little bit torn there because I
think Hollywood shouldn't necessarily be
a platform for any message but then I
also believe it's foolish to imagine
that it doesn't you know from from the
very basic of cutting out smoking for
movies and what that did to views toward
people who smoke you know I think we're
moving beyond I like to think the token
gay character in movies and TV shows but
I don't think we're quite there yet but
I think that's important to show that
even in mainstream movies to have gay
and lesbian characters who are
normalized they're not the token gay
character they are another character in
that movie and I like the idea of
sort of plot lines with in TV and film
that deal with gay men and women but
don't necessarily focus on that as a
sole issue because then I I think it
sort of creates a caricature of what
this is supposed to be so I i do think
to an extent Hollywood does hold some
responsibility but you know homophobia
exists in that industry like any other
while you know your agent or your
publicist can be gay don't expect to
sign on to a movie as an open gay person
and expect a big paycheck it's very easy
for me as a moviegoer to say Hollywood
the institution needs to change their
ways but i also think if they put a
openly gay character in a major motion
picture i don't think it would perform
as well as the ba at the box office so I
think we do need to take small steps to
reach that that end-all goal it's not
going to happen overnight and I think
it'd be foolish to assume so but you
know I think the American public does
still have this cringe mentality when it
comes to the idea of gay men and women
playing leading roles or roles where
they are the gay character all the way
to Hollywood that is fearful of even
opening up that possibility because the
investment is so large and you know
studio wants to make that bet
you